hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at entry points
on how we actually had to kind of define
an entry point for both our engine and
application how old that worked
definitely check out that video you can
happen already and today we're gonna be
taking a look at logging and how we can
actually use a logging library in our
engine so that we can log things to the
console in various like special colors
and just everywhere throughout our
codebase special tags and anyways gonna
be a lot of fun first of all I just want
to give a huge thank you as always to
all the patrons that make this series
possible if you guys aren't supporting
the series we've got a patient icon for
/the Cherno the surgeons wouldn't be
here without you guys so a huge thank
you as always and as a as a reward for
supporting this series you'll also get
things like source code to the actual
hazel engine that I've already written
as I'm writing it kind of just
immediately as well as videos per week
early so it's always interesting when I
make these videos because in a sense I'm
making it for like one group of people a
week before the second group of people
so by the time this video is actually
public for everyone for the whole
internet like I've already long
forgotten about it because I already
made the next video for patrons but
anyway let's get into logging so what is
logging why do we need it and what are
we going to do here today so logging is
just a way for us to basically log
events right I say events in kind of a
liberal sense like because events don't
really really be anything like anytime I
want to be like hey something happened
right
I want to essentially have a way of the
edge in communicating with us the humans
who are both developing it but also
possibly using it right so a good
example is we started the engine right
let's print off the kind of system
initialization things that happen maybe
even system information information as
well say system information information
like this information about the system
that we're running on whether or not
things certain things worked whether or
not said files were opened whether or
not like the shaders were compiled
successfully there's so much information
that we need to basically give as
feedback because to me at least like a
good piece of software is very kind of
client-facing in the sense
that like when you write a piece of
software that is even moderately
complicated when things go wrong you
want to know what's actually happened
right but your computer's running all of
this code it's doing all of these
complicated operations especially as the
code base grows it's gonna be doing all
of these complicated operations but it's
gonna be kind of keeping it to itself
that's not what we want right because if
something goes wrong or even if
something goes right we have no idea of
actually seeing what's happened and I
really like to know what is going on
right I just have to know what the
computer is done and what state is kind
of in right and that's where logging
comes in logging is a way for us to
actually as we write our code as we
write our complex code to communicate
back to ourselves and basically say okay
so I tried to do this this happened this
is the status this is what's going on
this is what I'm gonna do next well this
was an error you know maybe fix this you
know so many things like warnings as
well there's so many things we want to
do so apart from just being able to
communicate back to ourselves why like a
printf or like standard Z out or
something like that we also probably
want information about where that
message is coming from as well as
potentially the severity of that message
so instead of just being like you know
here's like a bunch of you know text
being printed out console we might want
to use different colors so like arrows
might be red warnings might be yellow
normal stuff might be green stuff that's
not important might be like gray or
something there's the kind of this whole
system that we want that really provides
us like with the way to just easily be
able to like scroll through our running
a console and be like oh no I saw a red
message there let's investigate there
that's probably something wrong well
maybe we know yellow is probably not
that great we can kind of ignore it
there's so many things that we wanting
to deal with so because of that what I'm
gonna be riding out or in logging
library um we could do that that would
take a while maybe like a week's worth
of excises I mean like a week's worth of
work really is what I was gonna say but
the idea is that the biggest issue with
logging I think is formatting different
types right so printing
just hollow world or whatever is easy
because we can just be like this is my
text string that that's kind of that's
kind of it that's done right but when we
actually have if you actually look at a
real kind of engine code base and you
want to print stuff you want to print
much more than just text right you want
to print numbers you want to print
objects you want to print pointers you
want there's so many things that we want
to print and we need a good way to
format that string properly and strength
formatting writing a good kind of
c-sharp style string dot format function
is a lot of work and probably about a
thousand lines of code right so it's not
something that I really want to spend
time on in this series I just I'm trying
to give you guys I guess there is I'm
explaining all this in a way in service
writing code it's just because I kind of
want to give you guys an idea of what
that's going through my head when I
decide okay we're not going to write it
ourselves were just gonna use a library
and for this it's literally because of
the fact that I want to be able to
support string formatting and probably
like you know an undetermined amount of
arguments for our actual log message and
that's something that it's much easier
to just take something good that has
been written and reuse it instead of
kind of writing everything else else
because then this would take over here
anyway so we're gonna be using a library
called SPD log so if we just open up
github over here what I've got here is
just to get up a drip and I'll leave
this in the description
I was just I've also started um so you
guys can check this out for yourselves
it's very it's quite fast it's even runs
an asynchronous mode and there's a
really nice usage sample here that you
can kind of look at yourself the primary
things that I like you know it's stuff
like formatting I mean if you look at
this these are the different kind of
messages that you have warn critical
info or whatever we don't have to use we
can use any kind of subset of these as
we choose but you can say that the way
they love messages is very kind of
c-sharp style how they've basically got
which argument is refers to so that the
first one the only one and then
different formatting options for kind of
that argument and you know you can do
like you know arguments in different
kind of order and anyway this is just
this is just great it's very sharp style
which is
really good and I really like it and
also if you look at a license of course
which we need to do for every library
that we use it's the MIT license you can
see we have all the permissions that we
need as long as we actually retain this
copyright notice which of course we will
inside our engine ok cool so now that
we've decided to use this how do we use
this now I could make an entire video on
the proper way to use third-party
libraries in your codebase because guess
what there is no proper way basically
there is c plus plus C plus laws dealing
with kind of modules or like just
libraries is just not that there's no
real standard way to like people will
have different ways people might be like
oh you know you see Meg use kind of your
own system if you didn't get maybe use
sub-modules like it doesn't that there's
no kind of language to find a way to
actually import libraries and use them
so maybe I will make a video on various
ways to do it and what I've kind of
found throughout my kind of career but a
lot of times it basically comes down to
pick a build system that you want to use
such as semuc or pre make or something
like that and then just make sure that
every library that you use you kind of
rice a you write that into your build
system and then for things like this you
either can kind of maintain them
separately and just update them kind of
as updates come out or you can add them
like as I get somewhat if you didn't yet
you cannot add them as it gets
sub-module that's probably the best way
to do it for that but there's still kind
of noir there's no right way to do
things and eventually things will go out
of date or eventually like you'll run
into a library you want to use that
doesn't use the build system you use so
you'll have to write your own kind of
you know for example I want to use
something I'm using semuc as an example
I'm not actually in this series and
probably warrant but anyway I'm using
say make I decided to use this this
doesn't have same egg okay I have to
write my own say Mac OS this file to
make this compile for CA and then
I use that in my code that's essentially
something that you'll probably end up
having to do for libraries unless
everything happens to use the build
system that you're using and also
happens to be for example on year as
like on Veron gets kind of version
control system so you can just use it as
a sub module so anyway the whole thing
is a mess and I'm like I don't want to
spend too much time talking about it
but let's actually just kind of download
this into our project so all we could do
there's a number of things that we could
do we could just clone or download this
just download a zip file and unzip it
into our directory we could clone this
into its own directory and then copy the
files or what I'm going to do is
actually add it as a sub module to our
hazel repository so what this means is
that we don't actually kind of have the
code base in our code base it's
basically like it's basically we're
referencing an existing git repository
somewhere else there's kind of at a
remote address and then when we actually
clone hazel and we say also clone all
the sub modules it clones that and the
reason that that's kind of useful is
because it kind of keeps a ver kind of
code intact as well as less let's kind
of easily like kind of update to new
code changes from their repository
without kind of having to do anything
manually we can just update we can just
update that specific sub module because
it is a sub module and it's not actually
copied and pasted code into our own
repository I may actually make kind of a
standalone video on get sub modules in
the future because using this using it
in the context of this properties in the
best example but basically all I'm going
to do is copy this address here and then
come down into hazel I'll open a command
prompt window here and I'm going to just
type in git sub module add and now I
have to I'll paste in the path or sorry
the URL to the actual git repository and
then what I'm going to do is specify
where I want it to actually add this
code into now you can say that this is
really nice this is really nicely done I
mean it's got like include SPT log and
that's really kind of the only thing
that we need even though there's so much
other stuff like what I'm saying is that
in kind of into our include path really
this is the other thing that we need but
that's okay we'll sort that out later
so what
is where I want to store all these
third-party libraries is going to be
kind of in the solution directory
probably inside hazel itself because I
don't think that this will be like we
should probably have third-party
libraries per project rather than for
the entire solution so inside hazel I'm
going to make a folder called vendor
write which is going to refer to all
third party libraries and then the name
of this library which is going to be SPD
log because obviously I don't want all
of these files just in my vendor folder
so that's all I'm going to do I'm gonna
hit enter and then it's going to
actually clone that repository into that
project and what you'll also see once it
finishes is a file appear in our actual
root directory called git modules and if
we just kind of open that file I'll just
open it with Visual Studio at this point
you can see that it's created a new sub
module in this path there's a path and
there's the URL is company - okay so
this is what actually kind of defines
that sub module and inside Hazel you'll
see vendor s bitty log and then here it
is okay so what we need to include in
our project to get access to this is
include and then well keep this like
this so basically this is the path we
need so I'm going to copy this path I'm
gonna paste it into below right-click
properties for our actual hazel project
I'm going to go to say service bus and
then additional include directories
under general for all configurations and
our only platform here I'm going to add
this okay pretty simple now because this
is actual hazel what I'll do is I'll
make kind of a universal path that works
for all projects because we will have to
actually include this in sandbox as well
since this is kind of a header library
so solution directory and then hazel
bender SPG log include okay copy this go
to sandbox here yes here and I'll paste
this into here now this is going to get
a little bit annoying when we switch to
using a build system well obviously
define this nicely in the build system
so we won't have to kind of keep track
of it here in these property pages which
can get a little bit annoying okay cool
that is done now we can actually start
using that live
so let's make our own wrapper for it so
now at this point we could just kind of
use SPD log as SPT log but we obviously
don't want to kind of have like SPD log
log or whatever stuff in our actual
client game right this is the hazel
engine we should have hazel log or
something like that that's important for
a number of reasons first of all I want
to change the API I don't want it to
look like their API because their API is
actually quite babos we want something
really simple this is a log this has
come with a logging system for an engine
so really this should be magnified
that's kind of like a global macro that
we can use log level or something like
that we don't want to have to like to
start you dealing with namespaces or
having like long kind of strings of
Texas is like completely unnecessary but
also if further down the line we decide
to replace this logging library with
another log library we should be able to
ha swap that kind of out without
actually having to change any client
code because we want our game code like
when people use the hazel engine and
start doing things like a logging a
message and like if we decide to change
something internally we don't want them
to have to go through their code base
and kind of change the API that they've
been using because we've decided to
change something as minimal breaking
changes as possible is what we kind of
want so because of that we're gonna
create a log class which kind of wraps a
lot of SPD log functionality and just
ends up calling kind of static functions
I guess that will then forward kind of
arguments of whatever to SPD logs so
we're basically is putting a wrap up
let's just go ahead and do that so over
here on the hazel I'm going to right
click hit add new item we're going to
just create a class then we're gonna
call it log ok we're gonna have logged
on each level cpp hit OK and there we
have our log class so I'm going to type
in namespace Hazel this is going to be
class Hazel API log will include port or
H now this is probably made it in the
wrong place let's just move this into
the hazel
folder here okay so we've got quota H
we're going to go into log o CBP
also make sure this is the namespace
hazel and that looks pretty good to me
so far okay so now I'm not sure why this
isn't working it's totally in the same
directory so we'll just assume that's
Visual Studio being weird so now we need
to think about how we can actually use
SPD logs so the way we're going to do
that is really just include SPD log
slash SPD log we're gonna have to do
this in the header file and you'll see
why in a minute
but now we just want to kind of define
what our at our actual API will kind of
look like as well as probably some macro
so that we can kind of easily call
logging functions as required so SPD log
actually has quite a nice example that
we're going to kind of steal some code
from you can see that we create a new
console by just kind of creating this
kind of multi-threaded console we give
it a name and that names gonna be
important later as well because it's
going to kind of be appended to the
beginning of every message and then we
can kind of we have different varying
types so what I'm going to do is
actually kind of we're gonna make two
consoles one for the client one for the
actual engine so call one core I guess
and one which will actually be kind of
our app I guess console and we're going
to obviously abstract all this away so
that it's not a lot nicer than having to
call like member functions like this and
then we're also gonna probably set our
own formatting option because we can
actually use that pattern here to set
like I guess like a format for how all
log messages will kind of get printed so
let's go ahead and do that so the first
thing I wanna do is I wanna get out of
this I'm gonna make an init function
because we definitely need one of those
and then I'm going to make an inline
static st shared pointer I think it's
SPD log SP like lover or something like
that yep
SPT log logger will check that by
reference and this will be kind of out
for logger and so we'll have to do it
we'll have our core logger which will
return our let's just say core logo
which will make here and then we'll also
have our client logger
[Applause]
client logo which as you can imagine I'm
just going to end up being s or lager
and s client's logo also include memory
H or just memory so that we can use head
pointers okay cool so there we go we've
got to kind of loggers set up here and
an initialization function let's go over
here we'll have to define these two in
our actual translation unit here so
we'll say log for logger and log client
logo that is shed pointers here and
we'll have our void in this I'm really
kind of getting annoyed about visual
studios water formatting not working
here let me just try and build this okay
so the legal reference to non-static
okay yes of course these need to be
static compile it again
okay good succeeded again I'm not sure
with this intellisense or whatever is
going on is really annoying sometimes
it'll do but whatever okay so now let's
kind of create these two loggers that we
actually have okay so the first thing
that I want to do is actually set the
pattern for kind of how we're going to
actually log our messages this is like
the format so if we go over here and you
go to I think the wiki and we go into
custom formatting you can see they've
actually got examples of kind of how you
can use these patterns and a bunch of
flags which says like which part of the
message it will print and so using this
I've kind of prepared a pattern earlier
which is basically this so this will
kind of color it in the right way then
have the time stamp and then have the
name of the logo and then have the
actual log message
okay so we're basically just having kind
of the time stamp the name of the logger
so whether or not is call or client and
then our actual message so it's pretty
simple and all of that will be wrapped
within the correct color for that that
kind of severity of message so now that
we've done that we can actually start
creating these so if we go back to the
wiki or
just the repository and laughter example
you can see that what they do is they
create this kind of STD out color and
then mt4 multi-threaded so we're just
going to go ahead and say s core logo
equals STD sorry equals SPD log STD out
color empty and then the name okay so
for this we're actually going to call it
hazel okay and that's going to be our
core log of we're also going to make one
for our clients and I'm just gonna call
this one app okay maybe tap like that in
fact I'm also going to make hazel like
this and then I'm also gonna set the
level of which we kind of print messages
so I think if we just do like set level
or something I really wish this would
help me out I think that level of the
right yep set level and then the actual
log level and again Visual Studio has
just decided to not work at all so let's
just go here and see what it is as we
did a lower level level and then we have
a level enum which i think is sort of
tres is the kind of print everything
thing so we'll just do trace like that
and then we'll do the same thing for
clients okay so now we're printing all
messages from both of these loggers
probably a good idea to also expose this
so that we can actually set our level to
whatever we actually want it to be but
for now we'll just keep it at trace I'll
hit ctrl f7 to compile this file make
sure everything is fine okay so we get a
city color empty is not a member of SPD
log I think what we actually need to do
is include another file which is this
syncs file so let's go ahead and click
this just in LCVP file and there you go
everything compiled successfully alright
so now I want to actually use this stuff
in our client so what we could do right
and I will do this kind of as a test for
now in log in it this obviously this
function obviously needs to get called
somewhere so what I got a call I don't
really want to call this in our entry
point although I guess we will for now
we do need to kind of have like a system
initialization kind of function or
something
in which the engine actually is
initialized but for now again I will
call this in here this remember gets
included
into sandbox that's an important note to
make as well but I'll just say hazel log
in it
okay and if we go into hazel dot H I
will of course include log yeah so we'll
do include hazel log so if I build my
sandbox project now this should work and
if I hit f5 I think it'll just kind of
terminate why not let's maybe stick a
breakpoint here and hit f5 okay now I
need to copy that DLL we really need to
make a post build copy step we will do
that next time though I'm going to go
into bin-debug hazel DLL copy into
sandbox for place and f5 okay so it's
rotting this exists but I forgot that we
had that that while true loop Logan it
seems to work so maybe now let's try and
use something we'll say get a poor
logger and then I guess well it's just
to a warm because that should be out
yellow will say initialized log ok and
then I'm also going to do the same thing
but with the client logger and we'll
make this just a what's another one
infer having that's great so hello so we
should get two different kind of
messages from two different loggers here
ok cool so you can see we got a yellow
message it says initialize log and it
says that is from hazel and then from
app we get a hello printing and we also
have the timestamp which is cool
all right so how log is basically done
now here's the issue I don't want to
call this every time right hazel log get
get call log on board that's really kind
of annoying what I want to do instead is
create and mouse macros that make this
really easy to kind of use ok so what
I'm going to do is outside here I'm
gonna make a bunch of defiance and then
this basically going to just be define
age said for and then the log kind of
severity so I don't know why this is
already kind of here I'm no idea what
else that's can't be coming from anyway
I probably just type that close sometime
in my life so what we'll say ages ed
core and then era for example double dot
right because we're gonna have a very
a number of arguments and then when it's
going to pull hazel log gets poor lager
because that's H that core error and
then we'll say error and then underscore
honest for VA arcs right which is just
forwarding our variable arguments that
we had in our macro to our actual
function okay and that's that we're not
going to put a semicolon or anything
because we'll do that after we use the
macro but that's basically it right and
if you wanted to you could wrap this in
another macro that only enabled it under
certain circumstances maybe well that
would be definitely important because we
want to strip out all of our log
messages in distribution versions
obviously we don't want to we don't we
don't want to be wasting any kind of
performance logging messages to the
console that's probably not even going
to be visible when we distribute our
actual applications okay but we'll deal
with that later
so we have poor error we'll do probably
warn info and trace I think is probably
gonna be enough so era warned in fur and
a trace okay so trace will be traced
this will be inferred there's also a
fatal one but what I'm gonna worry about
that I think now and one let's kind of
organize these in order of severity
so we'll do trace info one error and in
fact you know what I might as well do
fatal because I think I'm going to want
to use that for a certain messages or
something like that perhaps so fatal
okay cool and I will kind of just nicely
aligned this that I want to use tabs or
anything because that can not work
depending on your tab size let's just
use the spacebar here to make sure
they're nicely aligned and we have all
of our kind of core logging I will say
or log macros okay and then we're gonna
do some client ones so clients log macro
so we're gonna copy all of these and the
only difference is going to be the fact
that they don't say call will actually
strip that entirely it'll just be edges
at trays and all that stuff
going to align these lips align these
like that and then instead of core
Locker I'm going to just use client logo
okay and that's it there we go we've got
all of our different ones I hopefully I
didn't make any mistakes here tracing
for a one-hour fatal for both of these
looks great
now I'm just going to go back into our
entry point and instead of this now you
can see this is just going to come aged
said core warned okay and then this just
becomes H said info okay
let's just print like a variable or
something just to make sure that works
into a equals five okay because that
should work as well of course we should
have variable messages of rather
variable kind of arguments that we can
actually pass in here let's hit a five
and see what happens and we only
modified the header files of course we
don't need to copy that DLL okay there
we go Mitchell eyes log hello VAR equals
five you can see everything works
correctly and it was really easy and it
looks really nice now and the other
obviously the other requirement is being
a macro which I forgot to mention but I
kind of did just then was that if this
isn't a macro it's a function that
always gets called but if it's a macro
it means we can strip it from
distribution bills so if I just
basically say you know if this is a disc
build I can define this to be nothing
just like that and that means that that
gets stripped from the actual build and
he's not included in the binary which
means that we're not running this in
distribution bills which is very very
important that's probably the main
reason not just to make our lives easier
but for actually stripping code out when
required so anyway that's kind of that
we do definitely need some kind of
system initialization kind of function
so hazel in it or something hazel core
in it or something like that we'll talk
about that next time for sure because as
we start to initialize certain things we
definitely don't want to be doing this
in the kind of main function that it
gets included into our app we want to do
that somewhere in the core engine and
then also I'm getting really sick of
this kind of DLL not being copied so I
think we're actually going to switch to
using a build system next time so that
should be fun anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did give me
the like
we've now got a great logging library
that we can actually use that's going to
be really important I wanted to get that
in there as soon as possible because now
we have a proper way to start giving
feedback as to what's going on to the
actual console which is gonna be just so
useful for pretty much everything huge
thank there's always to all the patrons
that make this possible
patron for such the churner is that link
you can help support the series it
really does help me kind of make videos
wouldn't be here without you guys a huge
thank you and you'll get access to much
much more source code than you see in
these videos because as I'm kind of
making these videos I'm also actually
writing the hazel engine on the side and
kind of as quick as I ride it is as like
that's the source code that you get so
as I'm writing it and might be commits
patrons get that source code immediately
so definitely check that out if you're
interested
next time we're probably going to use
finally switched using a build system
because first of all I want to start
getting this code probably working on
Mac and Linux as well because I know
there's a fair few of you guys who are
using that as I said I am gonna write a
kind of Windows only to begin with in
terms of the just I'm going to implement
the Windows platform only the engine
will still be structured in a way that
supports multiple platforms but I do
want to have like since people have been
like oh but I'm using Mac I'm using
Linux it is generally speaking a good
idea to be able to build this code
easily on Mac and Linux so that's why I
want to start using a build system and
also we can like I mean you know as soon
as we start kind of actually modifying
our project files by adding so many
include parts and also like a post build
copy step for example which we need to
copy that dll automatically instead of
adding that stuff to Visual Studio
manually it's better to just finally
dump that into an actual build system
kind of file essentially a configuration
file so that we don't have to then copy
everything across later as our engine
and project files get more complicated
anyway have you guys in this video as
always thank you for watching I'll see
you next time goodbye
you
[Music]